We're asked to convert 10 to the second power,
or 10 squared, equals 100 into a logarithmic equation.
Now this is saying, if I take base 10-- so I'll do 10 in yellow --
I take the base 10 to the exponent 2, then I get 100.
When you do a logarithm, it is really kind of the inverse of that,
it is really kind of the other way of thinking about it.
A logarithm says: "what power do I have to raise the base to, to get 100?"
So if I were to write log, base 10, of 100-- and I wrote the ten a little bit bigger than is typically done,
let me write it this way-- log base 10 of 100, this says
what power do I have to raise 10 to, my base, to get 100?
And we know from this, and probably you knew this even if we didn't have this written down,
you would have to raise it to the second power.
So this is equal to 2.
So right over here we are saying in an exponential equation, the base ten, to the second power
is equal to 100. Here in the logarithmic equation we are
saying that the power that we have to raise 10 to to get 100 is equal to 2.
So these are really saying the exact same thing.
And just so you get the terminology right, this, in both cases,
the ten is referred to as the base, this is the base,
and in both cases the 2, -- let me write it--
so in both cases the 2 is referred to, and I think you know this already, as the exponent.
And then the 100 is what you get when you raise the base to the exponent.
So these are two ways of writing the exact same truth about 10 to the second power equaling 100.